so it happens a lot um and I sometimes I
I point it out I'm like what what's
what's making you so negative I never
say why so negative because it's
ironically the question why is actually
it's an emotional question it's it can
be perceived as aggressive I'm like
what's making you so negative like
there's a lot of good things happening
here I want to know more so replacing
judgment with curiosity is is one part
um uh the other thing is to just allow
them to feel that way so it's like oh
yeah I hear you acknowledging the
negativity and then sort of moving on um
but but I also find that being focused
on where the future is um is important
and by the way not all negativity is bad
you know uh you know people who you know
are sometimes very often criticized at
work because they're always pointing out
the problems and you you hear bosses say
don't bring me problems bring me
Solutions it's like Well if I knew the
solution I wouldn't be coming to you you
know um uh I mean there's two there's
two types of negative n you know there's
one that is always negative and offers
no solution and stands on the sidelines
we have I don't need those people in in
in in an organization sure but the
people who constantly bring problems but
they're willing to roll up their sleeves
they try and find a solution those
people are are extremely valuable inside
an organization because they're helping
us see things cover our blind spots that
we're not seeing um and they're willing
to roll up their sleeves so not all
negativity is bad it's what we do with
that negativity afterwards we're willing
to work together or willing to just sort
of lean back and and lean out and and
I'll like I said I'll say it I'll say I
I I don't know what's making you
negative yeah tell me more we in our in
our company have a rule which is if the
reaction is above a five it's about
something else you know it's like why
did you leave the fridge open it's like
hm clearly not about the fridge right
right um You always leave the fridge
open okay do not react about the fridge
sure sure absolutely so it's the same
thing we find that in work like people
sometimes get very amped up about
something and you sort of pay attention
like that reaction to what we're talking
about don't match this is about
something else and this is where good
leadership and good human skills come
into play which is are you able to read
the room and figure out what's going on
here are they having a bad day is there
something else or is there something
that I don't know about the work that
we're doing that I can easily help
address and fix or did somebody just
hangry or tired and that's okay too
companies so rarely teach us the human
skills of how to have difficult
conversation so if somebody's constantly
negative and it is actually bringing you
or the team down how do you address that
without making it overly aggressive how
do you address that in a way that they
will hear you and so the ability to say
I need to have a difficult conversation
with you on third in Thursday's meeting
you were so negative it brought the
team's energy down and I'm I fear that
if you continue to bring that negative
energy to all of our meetings that it's
going to demoralize the team and then
learn to be quiet and allow somebody to
soak that in like that that interaction
we don't teach that and so usually it
comes out wrong and usually it escalates
or usually we avoid it we get passive
aggressive at work as well and so things
never get addressed
um uh but I think learning the skills of
of difficult human interaction by the
way human interaction is very often
difficult um uh is is a massive
opportunity for for Corporate America
today